on this episode we talk about bookstore
marketing hashtags and recycling content
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee shut up
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 68 of the askgaryvee
show
I'm a little bit of a roll three in a
row
we started in 2015 very bumpy
and by the way if we're lucky enough to
continue the show into 2016 we will
start that very bumpy 17 as January
between CES Sundance Super Bowl I do two
or three speeches every year in January
because people try to pump up their
company or do things right so January is
always a little tricky home first four
months is tricky as you can tell not as
many peeps in the background this
morning a little early here to pump out
askgaryvee devoted to the vaynernation I
appreciate you guys when I still want to
talk about by the way the two videos I'm
going to link them up again do you rock
I'm sorry but like just feeling the
Twitter video and obviously I mean
you've seen your organic starting point
for the one is greater than zero so
people really appreciating that video so
let's get into the show Abram asks how
do you optimize the use of hashtags for
campaigns hashtag it was a great
question I think we can get very
detailed for the vaynernation on this
hashtag culture is very very important
specifically to Instagram and Twitter so
let's start there that is really the two
places it massively over endemic says
some level Pinterest as well less on
Facebook you know tumblr for a while
there was very very important so but
snapchat not at all so LinkedIn not
really so you know we're really talking
really talking Twitter and an Instagram
first and foremost there's another
question that's going to be on the
episode and a couple questions where the
guy used
17:18 hashtags is his entire kind of
post I think hashtags are incredible way
to get discovered I think it's important
to think about the two ways I think
you're asking how do I get my hashtag
going right I think and even not by
answering that it's going to help a lot
of people look here so you know I have
the askgaryvee hashtag slash you know
hashtag ask gary vee askgaryvee show i
use on instagram and twitter but I'm
really just using that for fans that are
looking to go down the rabbit hole more
than getting it away for awareness your
for a campaign and I think people really
need to understand a couple things
number one hashtags are not ownable
let's just you know I'm going for bit
podcast listeners I'm going for a big
dramatic pause here you should seen the
way I reacted we shouldn't do it again
and it's important that you understand
this it is insane to me that people in
2015 still think they can own a hashtag
I walk into tons of meetings when the
brands like let's own the hashtag get
them and I'm like the hell are you
talking about
first and foremost any hashtag you can
create tomorrow I can jump in and make a
hashtag so you know we can remember all
the way to the infamous two thousand
eight or nine time when skittles put out
that hashtag and then people started
putting things that were very crude
against it because skittles homepage was
a filter and a stream of everybody using
the hash tagging and all of a sudden you
know body parts and rude and crude
things started showing up on their other
corporate page because there is no own
ability around a hashtag so my answer is
this flip it instead of trying to own or
establish a hashtag for a campaign look
at the hashtags that are trending and
very popular on the two main platforms
already and try to figure out how to
reverse into them by putting out your
piece of content storytelling and then
using three or four hashtags that are
riding the wave and I wrote about this a
million years ago riding the wave of a
hashtag one of my first mediums I think
and so uh that's the answer
you know reverse it don't try to
establish one ride the wave of four or
five that are working that are tie-in
and be creative into what you're putting
out Lenard asks you've talked before
about recycling a tweet but how about
other content such as a blog post how
often do you pull a piece from the
archives to dust it off to republish
letting a great question as a matter of
fact you know India this is something we
should actually probably consider
outright and look back at like my old
vids ler videos I saw one that came up
the other day that is clearly not been
transcribed to YouTube I got somebody
popped up I thought was interesting
anyway my own little spiel there sorry
Leonard let me answer a question I don't
do it often but I've never had India
Steve's not here
a wine event last night is probably
tired some people can't hang um I
haven't done it a lot though what my
team here is helping me do is make
better pieces of content on current
current thoughts and I think a lot of
you have noticed I use the askgaryvee
show now as a platform to have a show
and then india d-roc stephane the rest
of team are looking for nuggets within
it to them form bigger pieces of content
and so right now I'm using this show as
let's call it the core and then
satellite content the written word
content the infographics the slide
shares the animated gifts and these
really amazing two three four minute
movie types that these guys are banging
out or a byproduct of it you know you
just kind of spurred its wire just
yapped with India the idea that we maybe
need to look back at some of the two
thousand seven eight nine ten classic
stuff and maybe put a new you know maybe
we go through a hard core 2.0 thing
right stop doing stuff you hate to point
out like like you know though I've
updated you know lost and and I'm used
Breaking Bad or something what did we
use the house of cards that's good
anyway so you know I think that I think
it's massively important that people
look back at their old content and more
importantly well I believe in context
and time unless it's evergreen I don't
know if that was it's more this time and
so I would say what might be more
important my friend is how do you take a
piece of content that you put out today
and then produce six or seven versions
of that thought across the platforms in
a very jab jab jab right hook standpoint
where it's like show show it rock show
it come on it's beautiful um you know in
respecting the context so infographic
for Pinterest animated gif for tumblr
that would be what I'd most focus on
from Josh hi Gary if you were going to
market a brick-and-mortar bookshop where
would you start so Josh first of all
this is a great question second of all I
really appreciate the love you've given
me obviously you put Thank You economy
and one of your instagrams tremendous
obviously the question was posted so if
you guys could catch his name
or slow it down go back and watch it go
check out his Instagram I think your
Instagram is really tight I mean look
I've always said that marketing uh
doesn't fix your [ __ ] product and you
know now you're now after being such a
great guy you're like crap where is he
going with this being a bookstore in the
traditional sense of the word is over
right there's something called Amazon
its shipping away it's just starting let
me say that one more time because I
think people are confused it's just
starting
you know the corrosion of people going
to bricks and mortar for books has been
on like Donkey Kong in an iPad Kindle
and Amazon world I think if I was to buy
seventeen bookstores out of bankruptcy
and I had to do it what I would do is I
would turn them into a live event space
where book selling was the secondary
aspect of it I would turn into a coffee
shop I would talk it turn it into a
co-working space I would turn it into an
event spot I would turn the physical and
the fun part is guys and this is a
little preview of I'm getting my hands
into Wine Library a little bit while I
brie second floor that has a lot of
square footage I'm about to turn into an
event space so I'm eating my own dog
food on this one so you know I would say
the content that you're putting out on
the gram and I didn't have time to look
at everything else you're doing is
really strong but as you can imagine is
that gonna make somebody want to buy a
book from you for you know 30 to 70
percent more yeah hippies like India
shower you know like she would do that
right but like that is a very no no
loving books is one thing India going
and spending 70% more I can see you
because I know you a little bit maybe
doing that once it'll actually do you
buy your books from Amazon know so you
know so you know I I think that uh I
think that um there's some hipsters out
there but they're not going to drive
your bottom line right that's the
anomaly not the standard and so you know
I've done the show for a little while
now and I would say that India and
Stefan's head-nodding as I was giving
that answer was a really good indication
that we're barking up the right tree
here so I would sell 30 to 50% less
books to
we're up the square footage within the
store no matter how big you are 100
square feet 1000 square feet five
thousand square feet to really activate
the physical location and find other
ways and means to to to make dollars
because I think books selling within a
bricks-and-mortar needs to be the
secondary income not the first play and
that I think that's something people
need to wrap their head around by the
way real quick don't finish the editing
that is pretty much my theory on retail
period like multi-use you know events
experiential McDonald's a lot of people
talk about mikado like I think they need
to triple down on the playground at
thisis right you know like so I mean I
don't know they people have got to
realize retails in a very new place just
leaving this message because you wanted
some feedback just got out of the gym
training for a strongman competition
shameless self-promotion for my startup
company haggle champ calm here's my big
question how do I overcome my
people-pleasing nature so that's um
that's an easy that's an easy answer
you don't you've been told by society in
your homies that that is your weakness
and I will tell you that it is your
strength what your weakness is is that
you don't know how to throw a right hook
I am all people-pleasing culture nature
and I'm building my entire empire on it
as a matter of fact my my new I've been
talking about the bridge or the
contradiction as my autobiography but
now the big book that I want to write is
the human Empire right how to build an
empire of like good feelings with good
people and like things like that kind of
thing and so I think what you're in is
you're stuck in the jab jab jab jab jab
business and so my intuition based on
your question is it's not about fixing
your people as in fact I triple down on
that I want 34 more jabs from you but
where you're missing the boat is going
in for the right hook and so you need to
grow a sack and ask for the biz Jason
asks as a b2b manufacturer of building
products how much time and money should
we spend on marketing to consumers
versus customers or am I better off
trying to brand myself
an expert and a resource and let people
figure out what we can do to add value
Jason
first of all let's let's directly put
the picture back right now and let's
circle the cow
I'm scared crapless of that cow just
wanted to get that out there completely
scared um you know I think I think
you've got an answer you know it's funny
a lot of times people say to me that I
lead the question in business meetings
I'm asking a question but really I'm
just trying to make you tell me what I
want to hear you just did that like yes
answers yes
you should become the expert put out
content with scary-ass cows and dominate
and put it out there and let it be a
gateway drug and kind of breadcrumb to
what you're doing and so that's a man
content rules the world you know like
you know it just does like I just
thought of Lauren Hill did sound like
Lauren Hill and as a content rules the
world like I don't a little anyway I
think I think that that is the way to go
about it I'm a big fan of becoming the
honey and letting the bees come to you
and I think that that is what great
content is today watching Tony Robbins
retweet yesterday's you know one is
greater than zero video and then seeing
the new CMO of Hyatt reply to it because
you saw it from Tony and then seeing the
president of Cinnabon respond to her
because of her reaction is word of mouth
content marketing social media execution
2015 [ __ ] question of the day that
cow scared the [ __ ] out of me what
animal scares the crap out of you you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
well as in fact I triple down on that I
want 34 more jabs from you but where
you're missing the boat is going in for
the right hook and so you need to grow a
sack and ask for the biz